do all human beings crave power no human
beings crave security
they crave love they crave adventure
they crave power but not equally some
human beings nevertheless do crave power
for sure what words is that deeply in
the psychology of people is it something
you're born with is it something you
develop some people crave a position of
leadership or of standing out of being
recognized and that could be starting
out in the school years on the
schoolyard it could be within their own
family not just in their peer group
those kind of people we often see
craving leadership positions from a
young age often end up in positions of
power but they can be varied positions
of power you can have power in an
institution where your power is
purposefully limited for example there's
a board or a consultative body or a
separation of powers not everyone craves
power whereby they're the sole power or
there they're unconstrained power that's
a little bit less usual we may think
that everybody does but not everybody
does those people who do crave that kind
of power unconstrained the ability to
decide as much as life or death of other
people most people are not everyday
people they're not the people you
encounter in your daily life for the
most part those are extraordinary people
most of them don't have the opportunity
to live that dream very few of them in
fact end up with the opportunity to live
that dream so percentage-wise in your
sense if we think of George Washington
for example most would most people given
the choice of absolute power over a
country versus maybe the capped power
that the United States President
presidential Rollie said the founding of
the country represented what do you
think most people would choose well
Washington was in a position to exercise
far greater power than he did and in
fact he didn't take that option he was
more interested in seeing
institutionalization of seeing the
country develop strong institutions
rather than an individual leader like
himself have excess power so that's very
important so like I said not everyone
craves unconstrained power even if
they're very ambitious and of course
Washington was very ambitious he was a
successful general before he was a
president so that clearly comes from the
influences on your life where you grow
up how you grow up how you raised what
kind of values are imparted to you along
the way
you can understand power as the ability
to share or you can understand or the
ability to advance something for the
collective in a collective process not
an individual process so power comes in
many different varieties and ambition
doesn't always equate to despotic power
the spotted power is something different
from ordinary institutional power that
we see right the president of MIT does
not have unconstrained power the
president of MIT rightly must consult
with other members of the administration
with the faculty members to a certain
extent with the student body and
certainly with the trustees of MIT those
constraints are make the institution
strong and enduring and make the
decisions better than they would be if
he had on constrained power but you
can't say that the president is not
ambitious of course the president is
ambitious we worry about unconstrained
power we worry about executive authority
that's not limited
that's the definition of
authoritarianism or tyranny unlimited or
barely limited executive authority
executive authority is necessary to
carry out many functions we all
understand that that's why MIT has an
executive has a president but unlimited
or largely unconstrained executive power
is detrimental to even the person who
exercises that power so what do you
think it's an interesting notion we kind
of take it for granted that constraints
on executive power is a good thing but
why is that necessarily true so what is
it about absolute power that does
something bad to the human mind so you
know the popular saying of absolute
power corrupts absolutely is that the
case that the power in itself is the
thing that corrupts the mind in some
kind of way where it leads to a bad
leadership over time people make more
mistakes when they're not challenged
when they don't have to explain things
and get others to vote and go along with
it when they can make a decision without
anybody being able to block their
decision or to have input necessarily on
their decision you're more prone to
mistakes you're more prone to extremism
there's a temptation there for example
we have separation of powers in the
United States the Congress right has
Authority that the president doesn't
have as for example in budgeting the
so-called power of the purse this can be
very frustrating people want to see
things happen and they complained that
there's a do-nothing Congress or that
the situation is stalemated but actually
that's potentially a good thing in fact
that's how our system was designed our
system was designed to prevent things
happening in government and there's
frustration with that but ultimately
that's the strength of the institution
we have and so when you see
unconstrained executive authority there
can be a lot of dynamism a lot of things
can get done quickly but those things
can be like for example what happened in
China under Mao or what happened in the
Soviet Union under Stalin or what
happened in Haiti on the Papa Doc and
then baby doc or fill in the blank right
what happens sometimes in corporations
where a corporate leader is not
constrained by the shareholders by the
board or by anything and they can seem
to be a genius for a while but
eventually it catches up to them and so
the idea of constraints on executive
power is absolutely fundamental to the
American system American way of thinking
and not only America obviously large
other parts of the world that have a
similar system not an identical system
but a similar system of checks and
balances on executive power and so the
the the case that I study the only
checks and balances on executive power
are circumstantial so for example
distances in the country it's hard to do
something over 5,000 miles or the amount
of time in a day it's hard for a leader
to get to every single thing the leader
wants to get to because there are only
24 hours in a day
those are circumstantial constraints on
executive power they're not
institutional constraints on executive
power
you